well that creepy porn lawyer working for
stormy Daniels had yet another busy
weekend on cable television where he
vowed to invade even more people's
private lives but me it's time that he
himself was given a closer look here's
what the Federalists Molly Hemingway
suggested the other day he is the
frontman for what is obviously a
well-funded and well coordinated
operation that has received next to no
criticism or reflection by many people
in the media and I think it is worth
asking like who is this guy how does he
have access to special counsel or
Treasury Department documents who are
his connections who's paying for this I
think it's worth finding out just a
little bit more about this thing that is
driving so much of the coverage right so
who is this creepy porn lawyer we don't
ask ourselves the basic questions often
enough Mark Steyn does those he joins us
again who is this guy mark well he's a
very wacky guy he used to own the
Tully's Coffee Company which for people
for those of us from north of the border
sounds like a very bad joke he had a
company called you know you know if you
were successful lawyer you'd never come
but he called global barristers but he
actually had one called global baristas
and got sued for not paying for a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars worth
of coffee which is literally grounds for
a lawsuit I mean a guy I don't quite
understand this guy this this guy not
only doesn't he appear to have ever made
any money for his clients his own law
firm went bankrupt I've never heard of a
because America employs as many lawyers
as the rest of the planet combined I've
never actually heard of a lawyer so it
Gobber did his own firm goes bankrupt
this this guy is a very eccentric figure
and then as Molly said there is a lot
more to be found about him what is it
what does it say about cable television
or the other two networks that this guy
has been the single most frequent guest
like maybe ever well I think what it
says is actually that he's much better
at being a cable guest than he is a
lawyer I mean the tragedy here
if you like is what is that is that
stormy Paulo Abbey I betcha
poor old stormy one see 17 bucks and 20
she won't have enough money to buy a
decaf avenatti at his Tully's Coffee
store by the time this is all through
that item I don't but he'll it but he'll
get some publicity out of it that's it
that's a really good point
it's always the client who loses mark
Stein we all win when you're on thank
you Mark
thanks a lot Tucker